new tariffs on foreign made washing
machines is putting one Tennessee
community in a tough spot
of course bonnet Steve Harrigan tells us
why from Clarksville Tennessee tonight
washing machines will provide an early
test of President Trump's campaign
promise to bring back manufacturing jobs
to the US a new tariff just signed by
the president slaps all foreign made
machines with a tax of 20 to 50 percent
supporters of the tariffs say it is
necessary to protect US firms against
unfair trade practices you bring in a
washer that basically was made overseas
and you add a few nuts and bolts here in
America and call it made in the USA and
that's not true
opponents say the tariffs will only
serve to keep outdated companies afloat
it's unfortunate that certain
manufacturers who seem unable to compete
in the marketplace turn to these trade
efforts as a way to try to compete the
president has aggressively pitched the
US as a great investment for foreign
manufacturers there has never been a
better time to hire to build to invest
and to grow in the United States America
is open for business yet in Clarksville
Tennessee local officials say the facts
are otherwise the new tariff threatens a
South Korean LG state-of-the-art washing
machine factory under construction
the mayor says taxing imports sends the
wrong message our administration has
said hey we want to bring jobs back to
America and that's exactly what we're
doing is bringing jobs to America and it
kind of goes totally opposite of what
the message has been LG has already said
the tariff will force it to raise prices
on washing machines they're working
double shifts here now to try to finish
this factory as quickly as possible
so that these u.s. made washing machines
will face no tariffs Shannon all right
Steve Harrigan live in Tennessee thank
you